hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a review
of Jurassic world fallen Kingdom the
follow up to 2015's Jurassic world in
the fifth movie in the universals
Jurassic Park franchise these Reese's
and installments are still super popular
but they tend to produce some mixed
feelings and viewers so here I'm gonna
break down what I think is the deeper
reason why and by the way this is a
spoiler free review I'm not gonna spoil
anything that hasn't already been pretty
much revealed in the trailers and promo
footage for the movie okay let's dive in
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom improves
on its predecessor in a number of ways
but he may still walk out of the movie
missing out on the charm of Steven
Spielberg's classic as many of us did
after Jurassic world in 2015 what the
1993 original had going for it was
simplicity within a preachy complex
sci-fi premise the whole idea came from
Michael Crichton's novel and by the way
this is the same author who gave us
Westworld so you can imagine how deep
Crichton's technology themes can push
your mind if you really want to go that
far with him but the Jurassic Park movie
kept it simple the Dino DNA cartoon Jeff
Goldblum's endlessly quotable rants and
an easy-to-follow family rescue
narrative some critics dismiss Jurassic
Park when it first came out but this
straightforwardness along with some
still impressive practical effects has
sustained the movie's appeal over the
years and many felt this was missing
from Jurassic world in 2015 the family
dynamic centered around characters whose
behavior came off as confusing now it
was arguably impressive how the movie
worked as a sort of self commentary on
the way capitalist Hollywood ruins a
good thing by over selling it but that
deeper message just got lost in the
movies logic issues and that brings us
to this sequel which is written by the
same team behind drastic world but now
directed by ji Bayona known for the
horror film the orphanage and the
disaster movie The Impossible both great
movies critics are saying fallen Kingdom
struggles with the same kind of logic
issues at Jurassic world did but the way
I see it fallen Kingdom benefits from an
improved premise and sequences that
embrace the spectacle and joy of the
original Jurassic Park it just seems to
get bored with the tone premise fallen
Kingdom picks up three years after
Jurassic world with Isla Nublar and the
ruins of the parks set to be destroyed
by a volcano wiping out all of the
dinosaurs as Congress debates whether to
intervene and save the dinos Claire
Bryce Dallas Howard
now a dinosaur conservation activist
takes an assignment from Benjamin
Lockwood former partner to John Hammond
to rescue some of the dinosaurs that
includes the Raptor blue requiring the
help of Owen Chris Pratt now this solid
premise creates three big benefits for
fallen kingdom one it's set up some
cleverly directed action
phaona is truly a gifted director when
it comes to visual spectacle and he
understands how to frame the dinosaurs
and interesting ways to deliver payoff
in the first half without spoiling
exactly what happens the movie opens
with a truly thrilling sequence set in a
rainstorm actually reminded me a lot of
the rainstorm sequence in the original
dress apart later there's a great cliff
side dive in a gyrus fear that recalls
the claustrophobia of Spielberg's
trailer sequence in the lost world and
Bayona shoots this in a compelling long
take the heroes narrowly escaped from
intricately plotted dilemmas and it's
all just very fun and this overall sense
of joy is what I assume people who are
tweeting about how much they enjoyed
this sequel are referring to the island
portion of the movie also leads to
another benefit for fallen Kingdom
humanizing the monsters by recasting
them as good guys I think one thing we
forget about the original Jurassic Park
was how much it avoided pure
demonization those dinos were natural
threats and human genetic engineers
meddling with that nature with the true
source of the evil in the movie
Spielberg included a lot of sweet
non-threatening moments the
Brachiosaurus sneezing on Lexi grins
pressing his ear against the sick
Triceratops inspiring the best and they
made a gift of all time at the end of
the movie the most heroic character is a
t-rex himself he fends off the raptors
and allows the humans to escape of
course Jurassic world tried to reproduce
this magic gave Owen a parental
connection with blue and it climax with
a showdown between the indominus rex and
the original t-rex unfortunately we just
didn't feel that same emotional
connection with those dinosaurs that we
did before and the decision to create
them with mostly CGI as opposed to
practical effects and prosthetic models
might have been a big part of that
but fallen Kingdom I would argue pulls
off those poignant moments with the
dinosaurs on Isla Nublar you really feel
their life-or-death crisis and the
sequel nearly pulls off a twist from one
of the best sequels of all time t2
Judgment Day
recasting the monster from the first
movie as a hero friendly to the
that makes you a little sad to lose now
to be fair teeth to also replace the
original villain with an even cooler
t1000 and these new dinos t1 thousands
but by letting this empathize with the
dinosaurs fallen kingdom's premise
restores the franchise's straightforward
rescue narrative as I said before the
original plot structure of Jurassic Park
isn't that complicated save the kids get
the hell out every Jurassic movie has
followed in the footsteps by including
children in the threat somehow to their
hang results honestly the success of a
Jurassic Park movie is directly
proportional to how much you care
whether or not the kids die but at the
end of the day any story that requires a
parent figure to fix the family unit
tends to fit neatly in that life finds a
way theme of the franchise following
Kingdom just involves that plot device
to own and clears relationship with blue
who becomes the endangered child of this
story and that rescue mission on its own
is enough in my opinion
but here's where we get to the problems
of the movie which there are plenty of
they're not that hard to find you can
read about them anywhere but I think the
core issue is the movie as a whole isn't
satisfied with its own dinosaur rescue
premise halfway through the story
departs Isla Nublar moving on to a
pretty far-fetched turn of events that I
won't spoil directly but I'll just say
it's kind of that stuff that Vincent
d'Onofrio's character hinted at in the
first movie now look I get why the movie
does this the turn sets up by onna to
deliver some truly spooky Dino in the
shadow imagery with the beasts entering
the world of man echoing the finale of
the lost world cool and it seemed like
the script wanted to go deeper into that
capitalist commentary from Jurassic
world to apply the if this then what
else logic of dinosaur technology to the
real world and try to evolve the
conversation
one could argue fallen Kingdom is trying
to bite the hand that beats it using the
greedy industrialist trying to weaponize
a pure piece of nature in the movie as a
metaphor for the greedy Hollywood studio
heads or we're saturated in a simple joy
that should have stayed the past I love
it when movies deconstruction honor
conventions like when Logan or Deadpool
defied the tropes of superhero movies
but these Jurassic world movies aren't
making those kind of creative sacrifices
to be truly deconstructive there's still
big spectacle based dinosaur movies like
their world hasn't really learned
anything from past disasters it just
keeps making the same mistakes
because let's face it those mistakes are
still a lot of fun to see unfold sadly
it just makes these attempts to evolve
the conversation feel really forced but
that's just my take I'm curious to know
your thoughts do you think falling
Kingdom would have been a better movie
if it ended halfway through comment down
below with your thoughts or tweet me
directly idea Voss and like this video
share it around subscribed into
rockstars for this kind of deeper
analysis and all the movies you like
check out our reviews and breakdowns of
everything Marvel and Star Wars Pixar DC
Game of Thrones Westworld thank you for
watching and as much as we hate on
digital editing technology one benefit
of chroma key is that our editors can
put me anywhere like this I'm a dinosaur
[Music]